so there's a story in the news today
about an only Fan's models son killed
himself so only fan star's son left
suicidal after classmates taunt him with
naked pictures of his mom the 13 year
old said he had no idea his mom was on
provocative social media sites and
suffered panic attacks when youngsters
from his school began mocking him a
teenager said he had been left depressed
and suicidal after his classmates
flaunted naked pictures of his mom from
her only Fan's account
the 13 year old says he has no idea his
mother was on the provocative social
media site and suffered a panic attack
when youngsters from his school began
mocking him and shared naked pictures of
his mom he said he confronted his mother
about the only fans account and was told
he was overreacting with his mom
insisting that sex work is basically the
same as working in a supermarket
posting to Reddit the unnamed teenager
said I'm 13 and my mom is 33. things at
school were never great I'm sort of
short so I get picked on a bit but it
was manageable this that was until one
of my classmates showed me a picture of
my mom naked I almost had a panic attack
it had to be excused from the classroom
I ended up not showing up to school for
a few days faking sick I was hoping that
things would cool off but they didn't as
soon as I got to school almost everyone
in class was staring and laughing at me
this has been going on for about a week
now the teenager says the bullying is
gradually getting worse and worse and
now lots of students have nude images of
his mom they are sharing online and his
mother shared a link to her only fans on
her personal Twitter page he continued I
was wondering how my classmates even got
the picture and apparently my mom
advertises her only fans on her personal
Twitter account some students from my
school follow her so they were able to
see the nudes and they have been spread
everywhere I don't even have a Twitter
so I didn't know about any of this the
worst part was when I confronted my mom
about this she told me I was
overreacting and that sex work is
basically the same as working at a bank
or a grocery store she said it also
makes her feel good about herself that I
should be happy she's more confident now
I I told the principal but they can't
suspend thousands of students or take
anyone's phones I've been crying in my
room every day for the past week I don't
think I can take it anymore
we see wrongful deaths death suits all
the time for institutions that push
people into suicide you know schools
um even ex-lovers girlfriends boyfriends
but why is there no accountability on
mothers that push their sons into
suicide for their own poor decisions and
it's so funny because
the moms are so incredibly selfish
they are so selfish were they just think
of themselves and they don't think about
the kids at all
and you know
oftentimes what I'll hear
is that this is just a fringe case but
when you have more only fans workers
than teachers now
um this is becoming a real problem in
society and what a lot of these women
say is that oh you know once they're old
enough they'll understand
I think this is so selfish it is so
wrong and I actually
think it's terrible that we live in a
society that wants to make this socially
acceptable the most important thing in a
society is the children
children are innocent they had nothing
to do with the world's problems yet we
want to keep forcing our problems onto
the children
um
yeah so I I think this is unacceptable
and I I think that we really need to I
think we should ban only fans I think we
should
I think the U.S should ban only fans
because
and and this is another reason why men
should have the children because at
least when men are sleeping around or
you know do being a dog whatever they're
wise enough to keep it away from the
children
but women are just it's like they have
the audacity it's so crazy